europe votes what do the conservatives
want in the interview leading candidate
for the European People's Party
jean-claude yoga a young got some yes
the master yanka for the very first time
Europe's parties are putting forward
candidates for European Commission
President you're running for Europe's
conservatives what do you have to
achieve if they turn it on for oil
becomes event I'm not the candidate for
Europe's conservatives i'm running for
the Christian Democrats it's a fine
distinction but one I think is important
by having all the major parties put
forth one candidate for the presidency
we want to give the people a clear
picture of who will take over leadership
of the European Commission depending on
their vote wow these data speculum what
I want to bring to the table is my long
years of experience as luxembourg's
Prime Minister has Eurogroup president
and as a decision-maker in Europe oh I
want to make sure the European
Commission and the EU tackle the big
issues in Europe while being less
intrusive in its actions smaller
problems can be solved better locally
community building I'm running to help
give european economic growth and the
european labor markets a boost i don't
mean that in an arrogant way i think
that by combining budget consolidation
with structural reform with repaired
growth policies we can more dependably
shape Europe's economic growth Fox
doesn't ago Gustavo venza president if
you become a European Commission
President meaning the political chief of
the EU administration what are the first
things you'd change about the EU venison
the fizzle we have to see to it that the
social impact of the Commission's
decisions is more clearly assess them
whose give the I'd like to see stress
tests for every Commission proposal made
under my leadership to measure the
impact on society Emma and
see analyst has stopped in VV activities
are we need to know how these decisions
that we put before the Member States for
that come from the European Parliament
actually affect people's lives how do
they affect growth potential in
different regions what concrete effects
to our decisions have on people's jobs
these are things we have to look at
because not enough attention has been
paid to Europe socio-economic dimensions
when it comes to domestic markets or the
common currency zone wouldn't folks
dunnage complete list since direct
elections have been held for the
european parliament voter participation
has fallen last time it was just forty
three percent why is that why is the EU
still so remote and alien to European
voters I skipped on ghouls and goblins
we should not turn on the national level
there's also a big gap between the
politicians and the people it's the same
for European Union politics of hiding
feel dimension for many people Brussels
seems farther away than their respective
national capitals it has to do with the
fact that we in Europe even heads of
state and government don't talk about
Europe in the right way and don't inform
voters correctly we act as if everything
that goes wrong in our individual
countries is the fault of the European
Commission and the EU it was a villain
those vests but when everything goes
well every time credit is due it's
portrayed as a success for national
politics of schools duncanville people
should be talking about Europe with more
respect than they do it's hard for us to
convince people that the old issues the
question of war or peace has gained new
relevance if you look beyond the e u--'s
borders to Ukraine to Crimea these are
the cool it's a wake-up call that the EU
has to use its power for peace across
the continent milliken the noise give
you that long to infuse demand we have
to explain to people especially to
younger people that Europe is getting
smaller than the
already is that's because Europe's
contribution to the global economy is
going to shrink rapidly in about 20
years no European country will be in the
g7 anymore we're losing our demographic
standing right now Europeans make up
twenty percent the world population but
by the middle or the end of this century
will be just four to seven percent of a
population of 10 billion mention does
house that means we have to come
together in Europe now otherwise we'll
have no standing in the world and no one
will listen to us anymore endeavour and
for young people who are now 10 15 20
years old there won't be any future
prospects in Europe Alton because we'll
be splintered into scattered little
fiefdom sort of like Luxembourg it looks
on blog availa to look felt so these are
Swift on we also have to figure into the
picture that here in the EU right-wing
populists parties including anti-eu
parties are gaining force and several
member states what kind of parliament
are the people going to elect will it be
able to get anything done if global does
feel can Parliament film Bullitt I don't
think that right-wing populists sand
extremists will have a large enough
presence in the parliament to block
motions look you cook them above
despedida violin I don't want to take
any bets on what the next parliament
will look like go to didn't go Tom might
prefer to be one of the people who
prevented these growing parties from
becoming a dominant force that's Pope
elizabeth is extremely if they did
become a dominant presence in Brussels
Holloman with the power to block EU
legislation killed their refusal to
cooperate would mean ongoing paralysis
for European politics you know on
Holland and I'm Cardinals kruseman we
have to make it clear to people that the
right-wing extremists and populist
groups that have been represented in
European Parliament not have in no way
contributed to legislation they just sit
there and moan about Europe while doing
nothing to improve it let me go position
within them not a young cuz even mr.
janka you were Luxembourg's Prime
Minister
for 18 years you're a group president
for eight years your work is respected
by people across Europe across political
parties so why are you running for
office again at age 60 you could be
spending your time writing clever books
about the EU yeah I'll be food and leave
oh come on I'd rather be doing clever
things for the EU you should I been whoa
I'll probably have enough time later to
write books and I'm already looking
forward to but for now I want to use my
knowledge of Europe my long immersion in
European sensitivities to help shape
Europe's future feel of skin I'm doing
in should you start inaudible page 2
Coons project if mr. i also want to help
make Europe a better place for its
citizens to focus on our Central
European duties so often that it often
annoys me when I see that the EU is met
with admiration and approval outside of
Europe while here in Europe that's not
the case also outside Europe we
encounter approval because we've managed
to bring about peace on the continent
because we've managed to create the
European single market of the world's
largest which is something no one
thought we could do and because we
managed to bring together 18 national
currencies into one unified European
currency the Euro having the Euro which
has remained stable this whole time is
one of the e u--'s highest political
achievements and it's something that
will continually protect Europe from the
dangers of the future folding of
feminism that side roads so yeah I can
listen you mentioned the events in
Ukraine the EU sees itself coming up
against Russian neo imperialism in
Ukraine and Moldova in the Caucasus has
the EU gone too easy on President
Vladimir Putin in recent years not info
bonito see no I don't think the EU has
been too easy on Putin Putin has been
too easy on himself by thinking he could
break international laws without any
reaction from the EU and other important
parts of the international community of
internal nodes fuga he's using 20th
century methods to try to change
international borders in the 21st
century
auntie sing push back from the EU the US
and other allies the riddle food /
patient it's also about respect or
European basic values which the Russian
government is violating for the oil
patient that's why we have to react by
stepping up economic sanctions against
Moscow but we shouldn't fall into
dangerous of war rhetoric and Evelyn
will talk soon we do not need a war with
Russia under your failure to fix it we
need sanctions and dialogue to slump
your hands on Siona mundial look dubai
gangs like the interim government in
Kiev has even warned of a third world
war is that really a possibility up if
Mona's recently I had a long
conversation with the Ukrainian Prime
Minister I don't care much for his
choice of words alternative when all
initiatives have failed we shouldn't be
thinking that the next step is war war
is never the next option than the extra
fruit vanilla we will not solve
humanity's problems with violence and
weapons index votes Yul and we should
distance ourselves from this kind of war
rhetoric dimension mr. Solomon up from
but I can only guess that the Ukrainian
Prime Minister wanted to draw the
world's attention to how volatile and
dangerous the situation is in Ukraine
and concerning Ukraine new car Nevel
miss Karina Pisa the Ukraine crisis has
overshadowed Europe's own financial
crisis now we're hearing everywhere the
euro crisis is over is that true got me
on the oil there never was a euro crisis
there was a debt crisis in certain
member states the Euro itself has always
remained incredibly stable still I would
not say we've overcome the crisis we're
heading in the right direction but it's
not over yet young covered tough ones
here mr. yokai you're here in Germany
for a Christian Democrat convention but
you're not even on campaign posters here
in Germany instead the German CD you are
campaigning with the face of Chancellor
Angela male
it's almost as if the party is hiding
its main European candidate for luba I'm
always surprised by this question us and
the German press are they going to have
Younker on the posters or not mot
insurance isn't on the posters either o
clock out this is your Social Democrat
competitor well you didn't have to
mention that but you're right but the
question is connected with mountain
shorts because he is on the Social
Democrats poster in Germany there's bits
and cuddly nothing I'm not on the
posters in Luxembourg either book but
then I don't want to be on some shiny
posters and I'm running so I can
implement the platform's I believe in
the dose that's a good song called
jean-claude Juncker Christian Democrat
candidate and candidate for Europe's
conservatives thanks for talking to DW
feeling thank you I'm glad to be the
Christian Democrats European candidate